[Music]
so the other day I'm searching to buy
these two big crown of chairs you know
these throne crowned king chairs that
they sell
I wanted to buy because I wanted to put
in our office so people can take
pictures and have some fun with it
and I'm searching for it and I forgot
about it I walked away then I went on my
phone so I logged on to something on my
phone on ESPN the same link came up I
said wait a minute that's the chair I
just looked at earlier then I went on a
complete different website in the
afternoon on Facebook it popped up again
I said wait a minute are these guys
spying on me you know are there drones
flying all over the place and they're
watching what I'm doing or their cameras
here right it's not it's called these
companies have figured out exactly my
buying process your decision-making
process as a customer and they know
exactly which one of the five steps to
plug into so you make the next step
which is buying a product so today in
this video I'm going to talk about the
five steps every customer goes through
you go through I go through before
buying a product and what you could do
to position yourself in a way where you
become the person they do business but
so again before I get into it if you got
any questions thoughts comments comment
on the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribed to this channel click on the
subscribe button and join our
notification squad so let me get into it
five steps number one customers going
about their business all of a sudden a
certain behavior produces a need or a
want I need to do this or I want to do
this now Aneta know want happens because
of two reasons one is internal the other
one is external let me explain and
internal issues the following you know
what my lips are dry any chapstick you
know what I just kind of feel dehydrated
I need water internal right
I need chapstick I need water you know
I'm just a little bit hungry I got to go
eat something right so then the next
step after I do that it's a different
step but the immediate one is internal I
want to do something okay next the other
one is external what's external you know
I went out and my sister's got this
Gucci purse I kind of want it as well
external I'm driving all of a sudden I
see a billboard I say oh shoot I want to
go watch that movie external I'm on the
unit I'm doing what I'm doing boom a
certain thing comes up on ESPN you know
a Hyundai hybrid
you know 79 miles per you know if gallon
or whatever it is right per charge I see
all these things and they prompt a need
or a want by the way I need this or I
want this number to once I have
identified the consumer that have to buy
the customer and need or want then I go
into research mode so I start searching
for things so again when your customers
researching what places do they go to
think about that they either go on the
internet and you go to Google which are
you visible there so on the search a
life insurance real estate digital
marketing pharmaceutical whatever it is
what's the search that they're gonna put
do you know the top ten searches for
what they're looking for do you pop up
if that's it again I buy your product
from you referral word-of-mouth
magazines website family friends
referral social media do you pop up in
these places that they're searching for
this specific thing three while they're
doing their search on these different
platforms then they identify their
options and I said you know my options
are McDonald's Wendy's Burger King okay
my options are this gas station that gas
station this gas station my options are
Walmart Amazon whatever my options are
they identified their three options okay
and they'll go and do their research on
what they need to do all this other
stuff the other day we want to buy
mattress for my oldest son so we want to
buy this tempur-pedic mattress right so
we go to this place and we had all these
options I'm an options guy live telling
my wife babe three options I don't buy
anything we had three options and she
knows that everybody here that works she
knows I like three options before I make
a decision so we go to this place I said
how much is this mattress he said $1,900
I said $1,900 yes he said sir before you
take your phone out I just want you to
know here's how we work we are the
cheapest in a marketplace and the reason
why we have so much confidence on what
we do we're all over the nation where
our products are everywhere
if ninety days from now you find anybody
that is cheaper than ours we will refund
you the dollar amount in 90 days from
now if you want to relive it back to us
we'll give you a hundred percent back to
your money guess what that's their
positioning they get a sale see how
simple that was that is their
proposition because they've already
thought about the objection I'm gonna do
cuz everyone knows you're gonna take out
your phone you know if I buy this on
Amazon yes sir
just bring that to us we'll do this ok
no problem a matter of fact right now
this is 999 your $1,299 yes but if you
look at it this is this I can give you
this 999 our products actually $8.99
but this shoot I lost because he's kind
of persuading me now it's a sales
process but they win I become a customer
of theirs buying a $1,300 product or
whatever was that we bought with this
tempur-pedic so that's number three
options number four as number four
happens customers process of eliminating
choices this doesn't work that is not
with this I'm going with this your job
is to help me the highest chance of your
product being the one that they choose
as they go through the process of
elimination whatever may be it may be a
face to face sale it may be a cold call
sell it may be a phone call seller may
be an internet sale it may be an
audience sale to your you know five
hundred people that are in the audience
or sixty people that are in the audience
it may be a radio it doesn't matter
process of elimination so if you know
exactly what the options are if you
bring that up to your customers say look
ma'am with all honesty when I sell
memberships I would say look you have
24-hour Fitness here you have a Gold's
Gym over there and you have powerhouse
over here and we'll Bally Total Fitness
let me tell about each one of them this
one is this this one's this this one's
this this one this you told me earlier
that this is important to you that's
what we specialize in you told me early
and outdoor pool is important to you
none of the other ones have an outdoor
pool you told me earlier that you need a
hip hop class we offer a hip hop this is
their schedules they don't have it great
product great gyms great people there
except based on what you're looking for
we happen to be the one that's the best
suitable for you is that something that
makes sense to us do you see any reason
why we shouldn't get started today not
at all great can I see your credit card
poem we filled it out right
process of elimination and last but not
least which is number five and this is
one that most salespeople or sales
managers completely completely screw
this one up and this is what it is after
this person but the membership after
this person bought the car after this
person bought the suit from you or
bought the phone system or whatever it
is the following day is their post
purchase experience this is when they're
gonna say I liked it I didn't like it I
regret buying it I want to return it now
if you have a
simple process that the moment after
they buy it you call them the following
day that takes out 80% of the regret
they're gonna have because they no
longer feel like they were abused or
take advantage of because sometimes
somebody buy something like the next I'm
like oh my gosh that person made money
off me maybe I pay too much I just
checked through the internet I could
have done this I could've done this a
simple phone call hey Larry this is
Patrick giving you call how are you
oh-ho Patrick hey how are you look I
just wanted to call you and let you know
I'm so excited about the new purchase
you made just want her to follow up you
know I really appreciate the time we
spend together do you have any questions
on what we purchase today yesterday
I'm excited the fact that you said that
what was important to you was this and
this and that would like a dinner you
told me you wanted to pull you wanted to
hip-hop class can't wait for you to take
your first class have you schedule your
first classes can I help you schedule
first class great then they get off the
phone there is no regret because you've
shown proof that they made the right
decision that they bought from you
that's step number five mark my word in
every business so many people are whole
band step on them step number five and
that's what leads to cancellations
that's what leads to change in our minds
that's what leads to them not wanting to
talk to you that's what leads to
complaint that's what leads to all that
stuff if you do that additional part
that gives you an edge over some of your
competitors because after they buy it if
you do a good job and I have a good
experience then I share it with other
people if I really like it based on the
way you treated me and gave me a
customer experience then I become an
advocate then I become a believer then
you have a floodgate of customers coming
to buy from you if you do the last part
right so now I have a PDF for you again
click on the link below to get the PDF
when you get this link I want you to
experience your own sales process within
your company how is that so if a
customer in your marketplace goes
through the things that they think about
what internal motivation prompts the
willingness to want to buy your product
and what external event creates
motivation to buy your product write
those things down then go through every
one of the steps of the information
research they would do which places that
would go on which sites that we're going
with social media sites would they go on
and then number three what are their
options what age do you have over the
other options that are out there to the
marketplace start eliminating the
choices based on the area
you're better than them and five give
them such a great experience that they
become an advocate and a true believer
for you but right and right all that
stuff up on a PDF then go create the
system share that with your team share
that with your staff and just see what
happens with your entire organization of
people becoming better at helping
customers not only make the right
decision for themselves but they become
more of your customers than your
competitors customers again any
questions thoughts comments comment
below and if you haven't subscribed to
this channel click on the sub button and
join the notification squad thank you so
much your body take care bye bye